Sorry.
Texting.
Written language is just one of those
things that's always been around.
It's a natural way for you to use words.
It's a gimmick,
but there's something you've forgotten.
It's understandable after all.
It's been a very long time.
Yeah,
a long time since no one on
the planet knew how to write.
Our story starts with the legend, the
tale of thought. Often feminists. No,
that's not a list. Beer hearing, soften,
Themis south and Samis after the
Egyptian God thought and Vince writing,
he runs to Kink, famous to share
this discovery, but to his Chagrin,
the king isn't impressed at all.
Looking down his nose,
he starts pontificating on the destructive
power of this new fangled technology.
Oh,
clever thought.
This invention will produce forgetfulness
in the minds of learners with the
neglect of their memory because their
trust and writing comes from strange
external marks and not
their own internal recall.
The drug you've discovered
isn't a memory enhancer,
but a mentioning enhancer
and you're offering students
pretend wisdom not truth.
This sounds strange.
It's easy for you and your world
full of writing to dismiss them as,
but here I'm out.
He brings you back to the early days of
writing when it was the hot new thing
and like many other inventions,
not everyone was on board. Okay,
so let's say for the sake of argument,
you don't want writing.
What are the alternative technologies
you could bust out your abacuses.
They'll help with counting and
doing complex calculations.
Maybe you prefer icons,
ritualized images that help you relate
to culturally significant figures,
events and attitudes.
The Keith who is an amazing ink and
information storage system using cords,
colors and not, oh, and don't
overlook rope memorization.
Basic option,
sure.
But it's really useful in preliterate
societies where sentences can be memorized
and recited by the thousands.
You're brain is bigger than you think.
Perhaps you prefer a petroglyphs rock
carvings with major cultural ties that may
refer to nearby places or
animals. Ooh, watch out writing.
We're getting uncomfortably close.
All of these inventions helped
humans keep track of their thoughts.
So what makes writing different?
What's them as afraid of?
Let's talk some ness embeddedness.
These things are all embedded in minds.
Tasks, rituals, events, cultures,
rip them from those contexts and you
rip their expressive heart thoughts.
Drug doesn't come with
so many strings attached.
It will DM bed you letting you record
any specific thoughts and letting future
generations read it in any context.
So human was famous, right?
Is writing an unnatural intrusion
or do you want to swallow thoughts,
pill and see for yourself what we actually
unleashed when we invented writing?
Ooh,
La France,
17,000 years ago.
It's cold out and getting colder.
Possibly dangerous too.
This may be France and this
may be the history of writing,
but there's nothing for you here until
you take shelter in a nearby cave and see
how creative some of your ancestors
really were drawing on their enlarging
brains and a long prehistory of
building ever more complex tools.
These early artists took to etching
and painting beautiful visual
representations of the animals
around them. These aren't words,
they're not stories.
They're pictures early.
Pictures like these start
to become very routine,
not necessarily depicting the world,
but marking and standing for things.
A place to hunt,
a place to eat.
These are pictographs.
The story gets sketchy here,
but it's important to notice
that pictographic symbols
like these Petroglyphs,
rock carvings weren't words.
They weren't language,
but they became more than personal
and communal artistic expressions.
They became regular and repeatable,
possibly mapping to specific things.
And for that,
these pictographs or in themselves,
the fancy label of Prodo writing,
many pictographs have an
intuitive giveaway quality.
They look like drawings of the things
they represent. Draw me a human easy.
Draw me a horse. Sure.
A river. There it is.
But how do you clearly and simply draw
less tangible ideas like playing around
or taking it easy or don't
even think about it. Uh Oh,
watch out for this major moments in
the history of writing meet metonymy.
This principled fellow lets you represent
a general nebulous idea with the
related pictogram or part of a pictogram
or a pictogram combo that's pretty
specific and obvious. Ancient stick
human is a regular old pictogram.
If you cut off sticks legs,
you can get across the general
idea of what walking, removing.
What about a man leaning against a tree?
What's the idea here?
Taking it easy. Resting.
These are idiot graphs,
symbols for ideas and concepts.
In some sense,
all of these drawings express ideas,
the concept of a horse concept of a human,
so they're all idiographic but with a
little imagination and a lot of time
extended idiot graphs.
Let you've cut and combine basic
pictographs to be far more expressive and
abstract.
Just when you're ready to grab that
Chisel and get your pictographic and
idiographic carving on someone more
inventive than you comes along.
Your pictures and ideas
aren't enough for her.
Gone are the days of Lascaux the
world outside. This cave is changing.
She says crops, cities, rulers, markets,
and she needs a way to keep track
of it all. She likes your icons.
She can use them for goats and Potts
fields and even long walks through the
desert, but she has an
incredible practical streak.
She takes those goats in those
pots and starts to tally the items.
She's recording one goat,
she says. Then two goats,
three goats for goats.
Notice what she's done.
These aren't simple depictions anymore.
They're not just ideas.
She's reading one word for each symbol.
She's encoding language.
Let's slow down here because it's hard
to overstate the importance of this major
moment in the history of writing
these goat counts or words,
symbols. Now, Loga graphs,
pictographs can be visualized.
Idiot graphs can be imagined,
but loga graphs can be directly and
consistently red logo graphics systems
emerge and flourish and
the early civilizations of
Mesopotamia, Egypt, China,
and Mexico, characters for
people, animals, land crops,
hundreds, even thousands of Loga graphs
for everything under the sun and moon,
including the sun and the moon.
Even after all these millennia,
if you squint hard enough,
you can still pick out the symbol,
scratching and weathered artifacts,
bearing the world's early scripts,
a Chinese turtle and Egyptian house,
a Sumerian head,
a Sumerian had eating bread, a Mayan
Jaguar, and in each of these places,
in all of these languages,
these were red as words.
We know what these Loma graphs mean
and we can put that meaning into words.
The world is now in a race to
fill itself with logo graphs,
but which humans started this craze?
Well,
the Mezo American started writing
more than 2,900 years ago.
Some Chinese characters or at least 3,200
years old writing popped up and creat
4,000 years ago,
but the two clear contenders,
our Egyptian hieroglyphs
and Sumerian cuneiform,
both a whopping 5,000 years old minimum.
It's common to say that the Egyptian
stole the idea of writing from Mesopotamia
and just came up with their own glyphs.
Common but not demonstrated for a while.
Mana genesis made sense.
This is the idea that one civilization
was king of all of the writing.
That writing started once in Mesopotamia
where people pressed a stylist in a wet
clay to make these wedge Kunis shapes,
forms,
cuneiform,
so the monogenic this story goes,
everyone else steals cuneiform and
re skins it to fit their own needs.
It's not a popular story these days.
Given what we know about
Chinese and especially Mezo
American writing along with
some very early
Egyptian fines, whoever's first
in these early days of writing,
all of the civilizations start
manufacturing hordes of logo graphs.
So many in fact that they unwittingly
unleash an epic memory burden on budding
look og refers from would be ancient
scribes to beginning students of Mandarin.
Chinese, do they really need
this many characters to write?
Surely there's an easier way.
Okay.
Say hello to this smart rogue who's about
to solve your problem with an innocent
mistake.
His father has been counting
sheep literally and he just
asked his son to record
a measly line in his budget.
10 sheep for uncle the son writes the 10
and the logo graph for sheep but uncle
he pauses and scratches his head
eager to play with his friends.
He writes the character
for ankle 10 sheep ankle.
He hurries away without a second thought
but don't take his invention lightly.
If you've ever played fill in the blank
or guessing games where you have to
sound out picture words you've seen and
used this principle for yourself but
it's not just for quirky puzzles with
funny so we've shortened the name for this
is another major moments
in the history of writing.
The name for this is is rebuilt.
This familiar language game lets you look
beyond the meaning of a character and
use it simply for its sound. Son.
Sounds like sun and by extension,
perhaps soon and sewn loga graphs like
the symbol for Sun could already be read
his words. Now with the rebus
principle in your pocket,
look at graphs can also be read as sounds.
This isn't just useful for getting
ancient uncle his ancient sheet.
Once as tech city planners finish building
their stunning capital in the middle
of a lake, the Venice of the
new world, keynotes teeth, Lon,
their scribes needed a
weight of right it's name.
They've been using what amounts
to basic picture of writing.
Since [inaudible] has a
stone Tay and a cactus,
naturally it's natural to write
it with two fairly obvious glyphs.
Then these become not just symbols,
meaning cactus in stone,
but symbols for the
noises they noche de land,
making them just as much Redis fun as
those puzzles you solve as a kid and now
you know the name for those.
You also know why there's a cactus on
top of a stone in Mexico. His flag,
it's not just for show.
How alike does this sound
like pronunciation have to be,
which sounds can we chop off pit
the Egyptians against the Sumerians?
One more time.
Egyptian hieroglyphs cut off the initial
consonant or less often two or three
continents from the
original word Sumerians.
On the other hand with their cuneiform,
take whole syllables.
These two paths don't just
add some local flavor.
Reversing out consonants doesn't just
impact ancient Egyptian hieroglyphs.
It leaves a legacy for later spinoffs.
The mentality,
these are either red as Loga graphs
or they stand for consonants.
Cuneiform leaves at different legacy,
completely unrelated languages.
We'll spend thousands of
years of borrowing and
reborrowing cuneiform to write
their own words,
but each time the symbols are red is low.
Good graphs or as syllables.
Flexibility is key here.
Look at this Egyptian hieroglyph.
It can be read as the logo graph for
mouth and AA or as the consonant or this
character.
It could be read as the logo graph,
meaning house or it could stand for the
consonant per the two consonants and the
Egyptian word.
Conveniently in Egyptian,
the little slashy below lets you
know when it's a pure logo graph.
The rebus discovery brings up the
tension between meaning and sound.
Is Riding phonetic or semantic?
Is it about encoding the meaning of
words or in coding? Speech sounds,
the old logo graphs. We're fundamentally
a meaning writing system. Sure.
This sounds like ray in Egyptian,
but what's crucial is that this is a
logo graph for the word meaning mouth.
Rebus writing takes a big
step towards sound writing.
This will come to stand for the
continent or regardless of meaning.
It may come as a surprise, but once
discovered, sound writing doesn't asked,
meaning writing, not at all. Indeed,
early writers notice that phonetic
writing brings up a problem,
a problem you probably missed because
of your comfort with sound writing.
A problem that meaning writing can
solve. Brace yourself. History,
because Loga graphs are
about to make a comeback
like all of the world's
earliest writing systems.
Chinese characters start out as symbols
that stand for words. A Rice Patty,
a person,
a tree.
These are logo graphs and they let you
depict specific language pieces to write
what you mean. But instead of requiring
different characters for every word,
the handy rebus principle lets you write
other things that sound like the lower
graph to write what you've say.
Sure.
You could use the reverse sounds like
principal to write any sound in your
language, but please consider this symbol
and answer the question that follows.
Does it mean son soon son or sewn?
Oh my. Did rebus writing get
you into a bit of trouble here.
When we see this character,
we could read it as a plain old logo
graph according to its meaning or any of
these rebus ways following
gets pronunciation. Which
one should you choose?
Think a bit outside of the jade box here
and take the lead of this. Han Scribe.
His solution is elegant.
Don't choose one.
Use both systems together.
What's that behind his back?
Is that a ho?
Yeah.
Major moments in the history of writing.
So here's the logo graph for horse,
but it also sounds the same
as the word for aunt said.
The rebus lets us write them both
with the same Glymph confusing,
not if you add the logo graph for insect
next to the sound to like character.
This says it's pronounced like horse,
which it is,
but that it's meaning has
something to do with insect.
You don't read the extra character.
It's a meaning hint determining
how to read the sound character,
so it's called the determinant.
Yeah.
One more mandarin example.
This logo graph means moon,
which happens to be
pronounced UAE using rebus.
Writing Yay also means amputate your feet.
Incidentally,
the word key is pronounced the same
way. Same problem, but nothing.
A couple determinative can't fix.
Add the determinative for
metal to this character.
Add knife to that one and let's leave
the moon B because that's already what it
means here.
Again,
the sounds like reading of a character
gives you it's phonetic component.
This extra logo graph clues you into
its meaning. It's semantic component.
Together they form a unit,
a whole character with a clear
meaning and a clear pronunciation.
Determinitive are very common in Chinese
characters, natively called Han Carrie.
In fact, since they hint at the
characters route, meaning it's radix.
Han determinitive get called radicals,
bringing back the characters sun.
It can be pronounced many ways true,
but at a determinative,
a silent helper character and
you can quickly narrow down,
it's meaning these extra determinitive
avoid ambiguous readings.
Which one is the sun in the sky,
which is a father's son,
which one means soon too easy.
There's something else to
learn from this quiet scribe.
He's using radicals to
clean up some ambiguity,
but even he knows that context matters.
He won't spell everything
out for you every time.
Sometimes this character means
for as in this is for you.
Other Times it's the verb supply.
He's balancing this tension in the history
of writing between what's easy on the
reader,
who needs more information to interpret
the words versus what's easy on the
writer, who typically knows what
he means when he's writing it.
Plus hand cramps.
The choice of leaving in or leaving out
helpful information isn't simply about
clarity and laziness.
It's a static throughout the history of
Chinese calligraphy from Oracle loans to
the rough cursive script.
Stylistic choices are made not
just semantic and phonetic choices.
Seeing through the calligraphers eyes you
can find in the history of writing not
only a vision of what
words and sounds look like,
but where words and sounds
go and where they stop.
When it comes to aesthetic
choices and Han characters,
none is more fundamental than the decision
to arrange character components in
blocks.
Bonus note,
this is definitely not the only time in
history that writing gets organized in
blocks.
So this radical sits on top
of this phonetic component
in a block making up one
whole character. The character for
flour, the idiographic man plus tree,
a man leaning a tree has two components
sitting side by side in a block and
they're the character for rest.
And here's one tree and its own block,
two trees meaning woods and three
trees for forest. Aesthetics aside,
what would happen if we took this sounds
like principal a step further and made
writing about the sounds is isn't
that a better solution to our scene,
son sown son problem. And one that doesn't
make us memorize tons of characters.
Yeah.
Okay.
Am I a stone worker? Etches elaborate
rows of characters onto a stele.
A tall stone brought in from far away.
That's now standing straight
up in the middle of the city.
The characters he's carving. Look more
like detailed pictures than writing,
but don't let that fool eel take a
look at this block. It means mountain,
but it's not.
Although the graph standing for mountain,
it's not a rebus symbol for think of a
word that rhymes with sheep mountains.
It's actually a block of two sound
symbols that spell the word [inaudible].
The Mayan word for mountain.
That's great for climbers,
but chocolate lovers may instead prefer
to sampled these three symbols that
together. Spell the word cat. Cow
Cocoa. There's a nifty shortcut here.
This bit doesn't even mean car.
It's actually a syllable
multiplier or iteration mark,
if you want the fancy name.
Sure.
I think you're being watched
over there in the jungle.
Maybe not.
Hmm.
Major moments in the history of
writing both of these Maya glyphs,
combined syllable characters
into blocks to write words.
This is full fledged sound writing.
These are Loga graphs that happened
to be read as sounds. They are sounds,
sounds capable of writing any syllable
and the language in a full syllabary like
the classical Maya script.
There are separate characters for just
about every possible syllable in the
language.
No longer must do invent
new word characters you can
make do with a much smaller
set of syllable characters.
Nice,
but syllable writing comes
with its own set of problems.
Here's a cliff that's quite
useful around these parts. Jaguar,
the where does actually belong,
but have you noticed something about the
Mayan syllabary consonant plus bowel,
continent plus bowel,
more consonants plus more vowels.
All of these syllables,
Indian vowels.
How in the world are you supposed
to write the lump in Balaam,
shifty scripty syllabi.
Dairies have grappled with this problem
and settled on two solutions. One,
leave out the final letter.
Just ignore it.
The term for this is under spelling
because you're not fully spelling the word
and it's a good solution because you
know ignoring your problems makes them go
away. Option to spell the last
letter with an extra syllable.
They use a syllable that just repeats the
last bowel so that we know we can just
ignore the final vowel.
This gets called the echo vowel.
Mayan likes number two a lot.
So the cow is Kakoa.
Well,
because times to Wa wheats,
the mountain is actually,
we'd see. And your new pet
Balaam is spelled Bala Ma.
Cross out the echo vowels and the
words practically read themselves.
Your new friend pulls you along
to show you another project.
He's working on an Amati Codex.
That's a paper book. Yes,
he has paper and yes books,
but that's not what's got him excited.
He folds open the book he's working
on maybe to share new ideas. No,
to brag about how inventive
and potentially efficient
his writing system is.
Know for his people.
The invention of the new
wasn't about ditching the old.
He shows you how creative he's been
with the characters you learned.
He shows you a mountain and calls it
weeds and then a Jaguar and calls it Bilam
Loga graphs. Wait a second,
you stop and ask him,
which is the correct way to write belong.
He writes Balama.
You ask him to write it again,
and he writes the logo graph,
but with the syllable and again,
but he writes the logo
graph plus two syllables.
He smiles mischievously.
They're all below them.
This is what he's proud of.
He can write the same word,
even the same syllable in different
ways and combinations without repeating
himself creative, but his use of
logo graphs plus syllables or calls.
The tension between sound writing,
meaning writing meaningful, determinative,
helped us choose the right
pronunciation for our rebus character.
And My loga graphs can still do that,
but the helping hand goes both ways.
The syllabary can also clarify the
sounds you should make when you've read a
lower graph.
Here's the character Jaguar,
but at a couple extra syllable hints and
you make it clear that we're meant to
read this glyphs as Bala Ma
minus the echo vowel. So Balaam,
these are phonetic compliments,
pronunciation clues,
sitting comfortably alongside logo graphs.
If that's all too complex.
Just remember that you can
write everything in syllables,
but before you have time to settle
into this land of Balaam and Cacau to
practice those syllables, a sandy
wind starts blowing in from the east.
Uh, familiar reminder from a far away
land where even more dramatic changes are
about to shape the future of writing.
Even in these ancient times,
Egyptian monuments have been sitting
and weathering for thousands of years on
their great murals and pillars. You
find rows of little pictures, sorry,
not pictures.
Hieroglyphs sacred symbols,
but despite appearances, this isn't some
mysterious, very iconic picture writing.
It's consonant one continent signs,
two consonant signs,
three continent signs.
Oh, wall of consonants,
plus a sprinkle of logo
grass for determinitive.
It's not that Egyptian was a harsh
bowel lesson, desert of a tongue.
It's simply did not write it. The
bowels. Imagine if you wrote this way,
would that work?
And then imagine if you could add in Loga
graphs to make sure you've really got
your point across.
Imagine you wrote like that and you're
thinking with hieroglyphs too difficult,
fine off to the caves with you where
you toil away with ancient miners on the
Sinai peninsula,
you and your fellow miners would find it
handy to leave messages for one another,
but there's no time for deep studies
of rows. A fancy hieroglyphs in here.
You need to keep it simple.
If you want another major moments
in the history of writing,
your characters look like scratchy,
rushed version of those
glamorous Egyptian symbols,
but they're meeting
doesn't matter anymore.
Nothing but consonants and the same
symbol for the same continent every time.
Take this character in Egyptian,
it means house.
The Semitic miners are calling a house.
A bet across any or top sounds suggest
that you can just take the first letter
of a word like the Egyptians had already
been doing with much of their continent
writing. You end up with a
letter for your sound bar.
Do the same thing with water, which
the Semitic speakers or calling them,
and you now have an mm sound with a
couple dozen elegant simplifications.
You create a simple,
reliable list of consonants.
An alphabet and you've given generations
of future children the joys of reciting
their abcs.
Actually at this point in history there
Abg D's sometimes called an object or ob
God because who needs that wishy washy?
See when you can just use an at k after
a long hard day of mining an etching,
you turn to find that someone's
been watching you this whole time.
She's a trader, a Phoenician merchant
who knows a good thing when she sees it.
She's already made major cash and the
paper business where they turn tufty
stocky, swampy Egyptian per pirates
into flat ink. Couple sheets of paper.
She rushes back home to
Phoenicia and smirks.
Think of the advantage she has keeping
track of whatever anyone else tells her
just by remembering about as many
characters as she has, fingers and toes.
All the kings can keep their up two's,
hieroglyphs and their stone monuments.
The future of the Mediterranean will
belong to alphabets and paper writing is
going portable.
She uses this newfound alphabetic
leverage to turn a huge profit across the
entire eastern Mediterranean,
leaving people inspired to adopt and
adapt her alphabet wherever she goes.
All of this
and she doesn't even write you a
thank you card. How hard could it be?
Writing is easier than ever.
It feels universal like writings
here to stay for everyone,
but there's a peculiar quirk that's
easier to spot. In hindsight,
you and your mining crew,
we're communicating in a
Semitic language, Venetians,
a Semitic language.
All of these friendly shades of the
Phoenician alphabet were being used for
languages that sounded similar and
worked much the same way. Even Egyptian,
no, no Semitic language itself is at
least a distant relative of the Semitic
languages with a similar personality.
This continent,
alphabet is being tested in easy waters,
but history is shaking things up.
Who are merchant friend
comes back for your help.
She needs you to deliver your alphabet
to a very different people living along
her trade route.
What will happen when the alphabet
gets leaked outside of the family?
Grace, no, not that Greece. Greece.
Before there was a Parthenon,
a stern old man in a trademark.
Sporty Toga seems a bit on edge as he
glares at the pirates sheet clutched in
his hand. Can you see? You
try to shrug off his outburst,
but he can't let this
go. My friend, my friend,
he recounts how 500 years
before he was even born,
when the walls of Troy still stood, the
Greeks had a writing system of their own.
It was one of those more elaborate
syllabary plus logo graph types.
But that script had come and it had gone.
The new Greeks were people on the rise,
but I know literate people on the rise
that people looking for something new,
something great. And this
alphabet thing seems great almost.
He calls over his close friends.
The Phoenician consonants are useful.
He can seeds. But why these
extra characters for huffing,
coughing and clearing your throat.
These are a barbarian sounds.
Greeks have no need for them.
And what about the voicing
noises like and Ooh,
how to write them? Huh? So
much extra yet so much missing.
What a mess you've tried to explain,
but they laugh it off
here. I fixed for you. He says, see,
he was going to ditch
the barbarian letters,
but he had second thoughts
and it struck him.
Why not use these on Greek sounds
for vowels. The one you call a left,
ignore the throaty catch at the
beginning. It's, ah, take that, hey,
but ditch the huh and we're
left with a valley. A,
you send up that tight Wa
and wow and it's developed.
This isn't just a small correction.
This is a powerful major moments
in the history of writing.
He's fundamentally shifted the
way the alphabet functions.
It used to be just the consonant
suggesting the pronunciation of a word.
Once you recognize the word,
the job's done.
But Greek spelling isn't merely
about writing recognizable words.
It's about matching letters to sounds.
A new principal has just emerged,
perhaps even a new goal.
One sound, one character.
You suspect that he's not even aware of
the impact of his discovery as he tells
you to drop everything and come enjoy
some dinner and dancing. Hippy, silly.
The party goes on and on so long that
your new friends don't even see what's
happening beyond the walls of their city
state. This consonant vowel alphabet,
this pronunciation writing.
It's spreading inspiring new alphabets
to the east with flavors like Armenian in
cyrillic popping up out west in Italy,
the Tuscans,
the Etruscans borrow it and
they pass it on to the Romans.
The Romans burst down and splatter it
among the Celts cinder manic peoples,
and eventually the world.
Such a visual rainbow of variations and
yet they'll all stick with the basic
principle of writing a character for
each sound, consonants and vowels.
Finally, you see your writing
system in this story, your alphabet,
all because a handful of submit
symbols got mistaken for Greek vowels,
but before you get over confident,
know that the history of
writing doesn't stop here.
This isn't the be all and end all,
not even close.
You're back in old Phoenicia where it
turns out the Greeks aren't the only ones
looking to buy a vowel.
Your contact in town is
still your merchant friend
of me who reminds you of how
she traded your continent,
alphabet across the ancient world.
That object spread to every language
with even a passing resemblance to
finishing. Every town from
here to Carthage has some
version of her object spot.
The Egyptians, those stuck in their way.
Traditionalist initially, these submit it,
speakers loved it,
they were proud of it,
but the days are turning to
years and that love grows cold.
They grumble that they're
stuck with these continents.
Just consonants clamoring for vowels.
They get desperate and grab a few
characters to stand in for a long sound.
Take a look. This symbol is
originally the stop between, ah, ah,
this one's a y. Uh, yes
sound, and this is a word,
but they're about to
become not these things.
Thanks to major moments
in the history of writing.
This moment hits you twice because it
brings up both an innovation specific to
submitting scripts and a more general
principle that kind of bins the rules of
the alphabet game first,
it's worth reiterating that object writing
systems are viable ways to write and
read a language they work,
but with one obvious shortcoming,
those missing vowels can
create ambiguous situations.
But what if instead of every vowel,
we just had a few helpful hints that
suggested the presence of certain kinds of
vowels. Take this letter. What
actually they called it. Wow.
Wow. Now imagine that we keep using
it and words that have the sound what?
But we also extend its use placing it
between continents for the similar enough
foul sound. Ooh. In the old op
job you'd have to write soon.
And son with the same characters.
S plus in everything else is
vowels and we don't have those.
But suddenly our extended work comes in
handy. Son Doesn't have that OOO sound.
So it's still s plus in,
but soon does.
So we add in the WWE do
the same thing with Ja,
which can double as a long I and
this quirky catch in your throat.
Pause between uh oh a left,
which can double as a long. Ah,
and you end up with three handy of
suggestors, the mattress Lectio,
these helpful mothers of reading
that show up in Aramaic, Hebrew,
Arabic and Syriac. But these mothers
don't leave their continent net's behind.
They still double as consonants. The
object traded the ambiguity of a vowel.
This existence for new kind of ambiguity.
Depending on context.
Each of these mattress may be a continent
or it might be a vowel one character,
multiple sounds.
This is a huge trend in alphabet.
Why invent new characters
when you can reuse an old one?
Repurposing continents for vowels
here and there won't satisfy everyone.
These bickering scribes aren't
content with mattress lectio Giannis.
They're not just trying to
tell son apart from soon.
The bickering scribes are bickering over
how to read one of their most treasured
sayings.
One says that it's such a fine point.
You wouldn't understand unless you were
incredibly well versed in his language,
but he makes an analogy for you.
Write the word news in a continent
only alphabet. It's in ws. Fine.
Now imagine that someone comes along
with their fancy consonant vowel hybrids
and spells the word nous in w s hmm.
Wait a second. He shows you a cheat sheet
he's been keeping. It's so easy. He says,
pointing out the little dots and dashes
above and below letters to keep his
vowel straight.
Put them here for an awe there for an a.
You can even add them below
one of the long vowel things.
If you need to distinguish, say an
eat, nobody's confused. That's it.
He won't tolerate the
vagueness any longer.
Effective immediately in all important
text where clear reading matters.
Everyone's to use this method.
And so for generations,
scribes would mark bowels
above and below the consonants,
writing bowels in what was once
a consonant, only alphabet,
but as much as the pious and
students whereby they're Dadi vowels.
Modern Arabic and Hebrew speakers stick
with the simple consonants plus the
extended consonant vowel mothers.
The optional helper dots get thrown in
like a life preserver for struggling
learners or careful text,
but grownups don't need them anymore.
The spice market in India,
the hooded figure in front of you,
apologizes for the kidnapping.
He needs her help.
He explains that his land has taken
part in history's most elaborate and
rigorous memorization exercises instead
of scribes. They had recitations.
These weren't retellings
of campfire stories.
These were whole libraries of
knowledge handed down for generations.
He says his name is [inaudible].
This is his land and he is king
after a bloody and violent war.
He had a change of heart and now has,
but one singular focus
to spread his message.
A lot of tolerance and
compassion throughout the land.
But he doesn't want to use the mouth
to ear memorization ways of the oral
tradition. That's for old
texts and old ideas. No,
his vision is to install massive
pillars around his empire.
Each one engraved with his list of edicts.
This he explains is where you come in.
See He's been keeping tabs on you as
you roamed the land of the submitted odd
jobs and he really likes this crazy
consonant alphabet idea. He'll take it,
but he also appreciates the whimsical
simplicity of accent continents with vowel
marks. Oh, and he doesn't want to have to
write the vowel if it's just a short, uh,
his language is full of those.
So he'll write funnel something like
this with these built in syllables,
but wait, it's not funnel that
final or is in a separate syllable.
He needs a way to write,
just bear consonants to tell his past,
apart from his pasta.
How with a simple hush
stroke below the letter.
Now he brags to you.
His system is complete.
Make sure you don't miss
the stuff he's taking here.
It's a major moments in
the history of writing.
Each of the character units
fundamentally represents a syllable.
It just so happens that unless the
vowel and not syllable is a short aw,
the val gets added on,
onto or below or beside the
consonant character on their own.
The base characters contain
that dummy vowel, uh, like Po.
But you can take that and modify
it with any vowel you like.
Certain bowels go in certain places
like e to the side or Ooh below.
So in India, characters or syllables,
but unlike a full Cilla Barry,
you don't need a completely separate
character for each separate syllable.
And all characters give
consonant plus vowel information.
But unlike a full alphabet,
you don't line up sequences of consonants,
plus vowels, consonants, plus vowels.
The hybrid combination nature
of the system earns it.
The name Alpha syllabary combos
are built into this system.
Paving the way for over a
thousand ligatures commonly
linked characters in the
Alpha Ciliary.
Sure.
Other writing systems developed
ligatures and their calligraphy,
but the indic Alpha salivary welcomes
them naturally as it's past all around
this entire slice of the world up to
Nepal and Tibet down the coast to Burma,
Thailand, Laos, Cambodia, and beyond.
The script keeps updating its but
continues to capture consonants and vowels
accurately like an alphabet
and to write those vowels,
consonants in syllable
units like the syllabary,
even completely unrelated Alpha Cilla.
Barry's seize on this same idea.
This is the Ethiopic symbol for ma.
This one reads May and this is Moo.
This is law Ley and loop. Now that you
understand that was still a berries.
You must answer this next question
if this symbol sounds like blah.
How do you write bay and Bu in Ethiopia?
This is your Gig is ABCDs.
The Abu Gita looks different
but works much the same way.
Your characters have never looked so
different even after the Greeks and Romans
took them over.
Maybe it's this dizzying variety of
writing systems or maybe thoughts.
Pill is starting to wear off.
Another time, another king.
This time in a Korean palace,
he presents himself as king. Say, John,
as you get a grip on your surroundings,
you began to tell him of your journeys.
Yet with the sweeping gay is
the king books right past you.
You've been out for a very long time.
Over a thousand years,
the world has come so far and the
scripts you once knew have to,
he reminds you of the old Chinese local
graphs and sound demeaning combinations.
Those are still useful to his
court to appoint. You See,
Chinese has these nice word units,
one after another,
but Korean he boasts has these elegantly
complex words with different pieces and
endings. Fitting Chinese writing
to Korean grammar hasn't been easy.
He tells you other people across the seed
who've gone through a similar struggle.
The Japanese simplified Chinese
characters by turning them into a fixed
syllabary, which they now use
alongside the Chinese characters.
So they have these syllable characters
and these thousands of Han characters.
They used the Han characters for
the meaning heavy components.
They'll tabulary terms.
Then they use the syllabary
to write little grammatical
words and word pieces or
new vocabulary words that don't
historically have their own Chinese logo.
Breath such a complicated system.
Gentlemen.
The king has an almost puzzle book
like he's holding back a punchline.
He recounts how an Old Japan women wrote
entire books using only the syllable
characters because riding with the
traditional Han characters was seen as the
masculine thing to do,
but he knows of another land.
He's heard exotic tales of the West where
people write out all of their sounds.
Logically, he pauses. He can't
quite grasp this himself.
You snicker as you think back on how you
saw the alphabet develop with your own
eyes and your journeys,
you would know.
So you sit down and show him how to
write every vowel and consonant with the
alphabet, a couple dozen shapes,
and you can write any sound.
You smile and think so simple, but
he lets out an unimpressed. Sy.
Why do all the characters so different,
so haphazard?
I mean you make fun and VA by putting
your bottom lip against your top teeth.
The only difference is that your throat
vibrates. When you say VA, he quizzes you.
Why do you write fuck and fuck? And he
goes on interrogating you. What about,
but why does it look that way when it's
just taking the VUS sound and saying it
through smacked lips seems
you underestimated the king.
He doesn't want any old alphabet.
He wants a writing system that shows
the various features of sounds that the
sound is made in your throat against your
teeth, made with your lips and so on.
He puts his brightest scholars to work,
giving them the humble name
of the hall of worthies, Ingo,
the experts and outcomes and other
major moments in the history of writing.
They develop Korean Hungle,
featural alphabet.
Every syllable gets separated out into
its own block. The syllables, consonants,
and vowels will be written
side by side within that block,
each consonant and vowel letter inside
that block will be shaped according to
its features. So here are the continents
that get pronounced with the lips.
See the similar lip shape.
Here's God,
and here's cut again,
similar sounds similar shape.
The featural alphabet was so
simple and straightforward forward.
One of the king's historians almost dared
people to learn it. If you're smart,
you can learn it in one morning. If
you're a fool, it'll take you 10 days.
Not everyone's jumping on the Hungle.
Easy train community accessible writing,
father's traditionalist who skip out on
the innovation and keep using Chinese
characters,
fit it to Korean Honjo or hand characters
even into the 19 hundreds still for
the rest. Writing is easier than
ever. It has its first drug star.
It even gets its own holiday.
Oh, writing. You've come a long,
long way from pictographs.
St a case.
The day that thougth invented writing,
fabulous warned him that he discovered
a drug that would make people lose touch
with themselves. If you're still
watching, you took thoughts, pill,
and software yourself.
The effects it really had.
It started with visual
depictions of the world.
Pictographs signs for ideas and thoughts,
idiot graphs than a transformation from
picture writing to true writing with
symbols that stand for words.
Moga graphs using those words to
sand for similar sounding words.
Rebus. Then those sound alikes
became syllable characters. Silod,
Barry's continent characters, odd jobs
and then consonant and vowel characters,
alphabets or even consonant and vowel
syllables, Alpha silver berries,
and if things get really
linguistic Salvey Alpha,
that's become all featural characters
grouped by their phonetic properties along
the way, writing had to deal
with the tensions and take sides.
Should it represent meanings or sounds?
Should it benefit the reader or the
writer contained maximum information about
every sound or just enough to
recognize the shape of a word?
Should it be flexible and
creative or rigid and consistent?
How do physical techniques shape it?
Oh Hen who did it first,
who did it best?
Maybe you've learned to make some
sense out of the chaotic noise of world
writing systems.
Maybe you can appreciate it.
Some of the problems,
each one solves the traditions.
It captures the ambiguity's it creates
or perhaps it's more comfortable just to
close your eyes and wake up back at home.
Looking at your familiar characters of
your familiar writing system plastered
across your favorite.
Yeah,
websites still somehow you can't
even look at that the same way.
It's just one invention among many
in the long history of this language
technology we call fighting.
Okay.